casey mize goes today we hear no
governor on him 25th start
slider's been great in his last two
really a strike thrower understands
when and where to throw each of his
pitches he's got up to four different
pitches got him swinging
they'll throw him out at first and
there's one away
this one laid down right in front of
mize and that's a good first inning for
casey mize 11 pitches
allows him to mow down the twins one two
three bailey over the twins starter
today six foot nine i believe he's the
second tallest pitcher for the twins
started out slowly but it's really been
good his last six starts 235 era
and upstairs gets a swing and a miss
scope retired two down
and fly ball short center out is simmons
and it is
simmons with the catch and over has a
one two three first
here comes derrick hill number nine
hitter for the tigers pay off the hill
fly ball left field deep gordon going
back still tracking it it's gone
big fly for derek hill and the tigers
strike first
there's a base hit to right that might
be more
he was thinking two right out of the box
he's got him with a pop-up slide
there is his first hit into the corner
the dude chasing it retrieving it buxton
into second with a stand-up double
so the fastball's in on the hands he
took one breaking ball and
walloped the second one
that ball kicks him away from us
buckston to third and he'll hold up
there wild pitch advancing the tying run
to third base
and a base head right center field
buxton comes home with the tying run and
another clutch at bat for jorge polanco
and now here's donaldson polanco at
first and a high blast to center field
hill going back he won't get it it's
gone
over the 420 mark
donaldson hits his 21st of the year and
the twins jump out in front three to one
that's a fair ball
fourth straight hit for the twins and a
weird karim
will allow kepler to go to second with a
double
the other way get down and it does
he'll dig for two
and he will cruise in with a lead off
double here in the fifth
the one two he popped it up behind
second base that's a long run for
simmons it drops in
that'll be an rbi single for zach short
who cares about exit velocity that is
production and the tigers draw within
one derrick hill homered his first time
up
drives one to left field get down it
does
tigers have put together three hits in
the inning and here comes the top of the
order
and a base hit
the runner might have been going that
was
perhaps a classic hit and run
with jeffers
taking off and simmons just bouncing it
to the open right side of the infield
and
there goes simmons ground ball to second
could be two
shorts throw in time
a job well done for alex lang got in
some trouble but got out of it with the
help of his defense as we stretch in
detroit brought to you by dte
up the middle another base hit for
harold castro
more than one hit today
harold castro
slowly wide of second polanco off
balance to first
ceno dropped it everybody's safe for
zach short
the 01 popped up right side
polanco or suno it'll be the second
baseman polanco
and that's how we end the seventh we
head to the eighth and another tight one
at comerica park in detroit down one
is a good thing for these lady guys and
he has the stuff change up at 91 down
and away two down and that's the key he
threw two good change ups that he got
badou to swing over and then he threw
that to that breaking ball at the pitch
before
but it's it's so important for him
especially against these left-hand
hitters to be able to locate that ball
down and out of the strike zone right
back at him down he goes candelario
makes a heck of a play to get kepler at
first base
that caught him in the mouth
did he get this glove up and protect it
or no
looks like he got him in the chin there
a little bit
is that candy that came over and scooped
it up yep
you did see it was turning away that
could be good
not that it ever is when you get hit but
you look to deflect that compression
gibby that came off the bat at 95 miles
an hour
we hope that he's okay yeah we sure do
emergency situation for joe jimenez as
he comes in from miguel del pozo here in
the ninth in a 3-2 minnesota league
the 2-2
in the air
behind second base
short puts it away and the twins go one
two three here comes the tigers heart of
the order down a run
whatever it is you gotta find a way to
counteract it but the big fly right here
would do it
another 2-2
a chopper cola may is going to have to
hurry
over the head of snow
haas puts on the brakes he'll retreat to
first and the tigers are still alive
nice back up by kepler right there
now the 2-1
back to the mound
coleman
throws it high
and they got him at first base
tigers want to challenge this
is that foot off just when he hit
oh yeah
the inning looks like it's going to
continue it was it off or was it on
i think he didn't keep it up
oh no he's up he's off
yeah he is definitely off
talking about
close rate
he's safe at first base there we go
and they're going to take carol castro
and they were taking time to center base
yeah they were taking time to set that
right
popped him up
[Applause]
kepler
with the call
and the catch
and the twins will head home with a win
in detroit